Успіх нашого алгоритму VQE значною мірою
залежить від стану та circuit,
з яких ми починаємо.
Я — Victoria Lipinska, і в цьому відео
ми розглянемо варіанти
їхнього проектування.
Давай детальніше поглянемо
на всі елементи,
які присутні в кожному запуску квантової
частини VQE.
Починаємо з еталонного стану,
який іноді називають початковим.
Ми пропускаємо еталонний стан
через параметризований circuit, який називають
варіаційною формою
з початковим вибором параметрів,
і вимірюємо стан
у базисі гамільтоніана
після пропускання через circuit,
щоб отримати значення очікування. Тепер
ми розберемо кожен із цих елементів,
починаючи з еталонного стану.
Типовий вибір для еталонного
стану — це нульовий стан.
Це стан, у якому квантовий
комп'ютер вже ініціалізований.
Для задач квантової хімії
можна також використовувати
так званий стан Хартрі-Фока,
що є результатом
методу Хартрі-Фока.
Коротко кажучи, теорія Хартрі-Фока
дає простий спосіб побудувати
еталонний стан, апроксимуючи
основний стан квантової системи.
Вона знаходить обертання
в просторі станів,
яке мінімізує енергію основного стану.
Нарешті, еталонний стан
може бути дуже специфічним для задачі,
і ти можеш захотіти
вибрати власний стан.
У випадку, коли ти знаєш, які властивості
має твоя система, наприклад, симетрії
або конкретну кількість електронів
у стані, ти можеш використати це,
щоб досягти кращої збіжності
алгоритму VQE.
Вибір хорошого еталонного
стану важливий для збіжності —
еталонні стани, близькі до
основного стану,
можуть зробити збіжність задачі
значно легшою та швидшою.
Так само важливим
є вибір початкових значень параметрів,
які ми подаємо у варіаційну форму.
Тому, залежно від еталонного
стану та початкових параметрів,
ми можемо збігатися швидко, повільно
або взагалі не збігатися.
Давай подивимося на цей графік,
і для наочності
уявімо, що наш простір параметрів
має лише один параметр.
Дуже хороший еталонний стан
може дозволити тобі стартувати дуже близько
до кінцевого основного стану,
і тоді збіжність буде швидкою.
З іншого боку, якщо ти стартуєш дуже далеко
від основного стану ось тут,
еталонний стан
a, тобі доведеться подолати великий енергетичний
бар'єр, що призведе до дуже повільної збіжності
або взагалі до її відсутності.
Ми детальніше розберемо це
в модулі класичної оптимізації
цього курсу.
Тепер давай розглянемо параметричний circuit,
що діє на еталонний стан, тобто
варіаційну форму.
Коли цей circuit, знаний як
U від тета, діє на еталонний
стан,
він породжує те, що ми називаємо пробним станом —
псі від тета, або іноді ansatz.
Саме цей стан ansatz потім
вимірюється у відповідному базисі,
щоб отримати значення
очікування для енергії.
Варіаційні форми,
які ми тут розглядаємо,
WEBVTT
натхнені хімією.
Однак май на увазі,
що є й такі, натхнені
квантовим машинним навчанням
та іншими near-term
алгоритмами, як-от алгоритми
квантової наближеної оптимізації.
Давай розглянемо
поширені варіанти вибору chemistry ansatz.
Унітарний зв'язаних кластерів, або UCC,
— це метод, спочатку запропонований
у першій публікації про VQE,
і він широко використовується
в задачах квантової хімії.
Зазвичай,
коли ми параметризуємо квантовий стан,
ми маємо справу з експоненціально
великою кількістю параметрів.
Однак, щоб зробити підготовчі
circuits ефективними,
нам потрібна поліноміальна кількість
операцій,
а отже, і поліноміальна кількість
параметрів.
UCC — це приклад способу підготовки
пробного стану за допомогою такого circuit,
і він походить із методу
зв'язаних кластерів,
який є золотим стандартом
у квантовій хімії.
Найпоширенішим вибором є унітарний
зв'язаних кластерів
одинарних та подвійних збуджень —
ansatz UCCSD, скорочено.
Оскільки UCCSD мотивований конкретною
електронною конфігурацією задачі,
нам потрібно переконатися, що ми маємо
еталонний стан, який належно відображає систему.
Це стан Хартрі-Фока.
Ansatz UCCSD зазвичай дає
гарне наближення основного стану,
оскільки охоплює одинарні та подвійні
електронні збудження в даній молекулі.
Кількість параметрів у UCCSD масштабується
квадратично з кількістю
спінових орбіталей.
UCCSD може бути дуже добре
підлаштований під задачу,
але на жаль, квадратичне масштабування
все одно призводить до дуже глибоких circuits,
які важко реалізувати
на сучасних квантових комп'ютерах.
Саме тому дослідники IBM запропонували
більш евристичний підхід,
де можна підлаштувати варіаційну форму
під конкретне апаратне забезпечення,
що дає ефективно
виконуваний circuit.
Тобто пробні стани параметризуються
квантовими gates
і адаптуються
до доступного фізичного пристрою.
Це дуже евристичний підхід,
зручний для апаратного забезпечення.
На основі цих прикладів давай поглянемо
на спектр можливостей,
які в нас є для представлення
нашої варіаційної форми.
Багато з них вже реалізовано
в Qiskit,
тому раджу тобі спробувати самостійно,
яка з них найбільше підходить
для задачі, яку ти вирішуєш.
Якщо подивитися на графік, з одного боку
маємо дуже евристичні
варіаційні форми.
Коли специфічність задачі низька, але
вони розроблені для реалізації
на реальному апаратному забезпеченні.
Вони також дуже виразні в тому сенсі,
що з їх допомогою можна виразити
багато квантових станів.
Однак проблема, яка може виникнути
на пізнішому
етапі класичної оптимізації,
— це зіткнення
з так званим barren plateau,
яке ми розглянемо в наступному модулі.
З іншого боку,
маємо дуже специфічний для задачі унітарний
зв'язаних кластерів, який чудово працює
в класичній хімії, але
WEBVTT
важко реалізувати на квантовому
апаратному забезпеченні через велику глибину circuit.
Загалом, обчислення
можуть бути успішнішими, якщо ти зможеш,
по-перше, вибрати еталонний стан
і початковий набір параметрів,
які створюють стан ansatz,
близький до основного стану.
По-друге, уникати зайвих параметрів.
Вони або збільшують
глибину circuit без жодної користі,
або створюють більший простір параметрів,
пошук у якому призводить до плато
в класичній оптимізації.
Які параметри є необхідними — це
специфічне для задачі питання,
яке потребує ретельного обмірковування.
Давай поговоримо про те, де наш почесний гість,
гамільтоніан, ховається в усьому цьому.
Як ми дізналися в попередньому розділі,
гамільтоніан після qubit-
перетворення представляється як сума
зважених рядків операторів Паулі.
Зрештою, однак,
ми хочемо обчислити значення очікування
нашого гамільтоніана для стану ansatz,
породженого варіаційною формою.
На щастя, квантова
механіка приємна і лінійна,
і саме це ми використаємо,
щоб отримати значення очікування.
Ось як це працює.
Ми знаємо, що гамільтоніан є зваженою
сумою операторів Паулі,
і через лінійність значення очікування
суми
дорівнює сумі значень очікування
кожного рядка Паулі.
Ну, це чудово, бо, як ти вже знаєш,
вимірювання в базисі Паулі
— це так само просто, як
обертання стандартного базису вимірювання.
Замість того, щоб вимірювати значення очікування
для цього величезного гамільтоніана, представленого
у вигляді суми, ми спочатку обчислюємо значення
очікування окремих доданків,
а потім підсумовуємо
з відповідними вагами.
Ось чому в багатьох матеріалах
ти бачитимеш лише одно-qubit обертання
після ansatz.
Саме це реалізує гамільтоніан
у кожному виконанні circuit.
У наступному відео
ми розглянемо, що відбувається
на етапі класичної оптимізації.
Побачимося там.